if I am NOT THERE shown then I must be
the wolf everyone I'm Lucy I'm tomorrow
and we have seen a little bit of Far Cry
5 I'm gonna be talking you through what
you bazoft has revealed about the game
so far I'm very excited has Colts called
we're very love Colts hot so you have
great weird morbid fascination with
cults so the reason that your character
is in Prague County where this cult is
operating is because you are a deputy
sheriff see you to the sheriff buddies
go and try and rest
the leader of this cult his name's
Joseph he is well mad like properly mad
he's got a bit of a Messiah Complex
going on I think it's important to you
know kind of establish the world or
hopefully like it's a lot like ours it's
in the time of upheaval there's crisis
people aren't sure of what lies in their
future and along comes this silver
tongued liar he's like hey guys I can
give you everything you want all you got
to do is submit and basically that's
what kind of The Clash is in in hope'
County
so in hope can see there are the people
who've lived there their whole lives and
we're happy there and notice this severe
downturn when Eden's gate arrived and
they they they made people join them I
mean like usually cult leaders trying
like win you over and grind you down
know these guys like literally they'll
take people go by gunpoint
yeah and it's really angered people yeah
that's why you're there you're there to
arrest the leader of the cult what I am
super excited about for the first time
in a far cry game you actually customize
the character you play us so it's no
more as a Jason Brody yeah no more AJ
it's you it's you you are the star of
this particular horror show and yeah you
have your two deputies with you when you
arrive and obviously at some point
plastic far cry style stuff goes wrong
they get kidnapped but that might speak
to another new gameplay addition they've
made you can play the entire game in
co-op with someone else which is
something they experimented with and
kind of take start taking baby steps in
in previous pocket
they're really going for it now yeah so
you can basically do the whole different
cult from the very beginning instead of
just having a pal poppy pop in and hop
out I remember Paco 3 had its own co-op
campaign is three different that is
super super exciting yep there's also in
the world itself a lot of turmoil a lot
of characters that you have to meet and
befriend and you can help them out yeah
however you want to sort of they were
saying things like guide your own
narrative yeah it's difficult to tell
what they mean by that right now I think
it might have something to do with how
you are bitterly the decisions you make
during the actual mission these NPCs
give you so like it's worth playing out
that the antagonists in this game on
isn't one there's no like you know one
main character
it's a family they called the seed Oh
mommy which is very very a lot of
imagery yeah
planting Joseph is the is the father
no no he's very ill he's an older
brother yes in comes our father and then
his siblings are Jacob John and faith
Joseph Jacob John and faith but yes a
you go there and those the kind of like
the main antagonists together they've
kind of taken over whole county and
poisoned it and the turning people
against each other and then along the
way you meet some of those people who
are kind of there's a resistance you
have yeah you have friends in the
resistance and so there is father Jerome
who has an incredible line in his little
vineyard trailer worth like if you could
no longer be the shepherd yeah yeah so
he's he's lamenting the loss of his
flock I've been captured yeah so you
know I think he's kind of blaming
himself a little bit as well because you
know there's bits there's lines where he
seems to indicate that he wasn't there
when they were kind of like twisting in
the wind not sure what to do with
themselves whereas you know ideally cult
leaders come in and they're like we give
you everything you want and he's kind of
taken them away but if he's not able to
Shepherd them like he says he's gonna
kill him he becomes the wolf instead of
the shepherd which is
quick look there's also Mary Mae so she
runs a local tavern and it's been in
their family for years but because of
the cults her brother and mother were
taken by the cult and father just
couldn't cope and it's insinuated that
he killed himself because she just wants
revenge and there's another guy who's he
was explained as just being a guy who
loves ya wholesome family man
wholesome man who loves wholesome means
like flying planes and stuff like that
but things are taking a bit of a twist
for him as well everyone's affected so
his his family his forefathers flew
planes in a war so that he could fly his
plane outside of a war and of course
things are going a bit wrong he's about
to have his own child wants it to be a
boy and he wants that kid to grow up to
be able to fly planes in peace so what
he's doing is he's attaching a Gatling
gun to the end of his plane I'm going to
gun some fools down clear up get rid of
these cultists which is a which is an
important way of going about finding
peace so we'll likely be seeing more far
cry 5 at this year's e3 at Ubisoft press
conference make sure you keep your eyes
peeled to GameSpot because we are going
to be out there in Los Angeles reporting
from the front lines excited to get
embroiled in this cult I'm gonna wear
shorts you're wearing shorts when asked
on CNN
[Music]